I don't know what to say really only
three minutes to the biggest midterms of
the last two years it all comes down to
today now either we heal as a mutt club
oh we're in progressive Hell right now
gentlemen believe me and we can stand
around and get the [ __ ] kicked out of us
or we can claw our way back into the
light we can climb out of hell no I
can't do it for you
[Music]
I mean I look at all these young mothers
faces but I think I'm at every wrong
choice whole a twenty thirty thirty year
olds can make I uh I pissed off all the
social media giants I pushed away every
Hollywood agent who's ever represented
me and lately I can't even stand
watching the clip of ana kasparian
telling me she's better than me you know
when you come out as a conservative
things get taken from you I mean that's
a part of life but you only learn that
part when people start calling you a
Nazi and you find out their life is a
game of inches
and so smuggler they're trying to shut
us down before this election the inches
we need are everywhere around this month
million and this Mach Club we fight for
that inch in this muffler
we tear ourselves to pieces throw
ourselves at super videos we change
minds and we even make sweaty jokes
because we know when we add up all those
mug for ballots and all those Minds
change that's gonna mean Duff in
differences between women Oh
and either we vote now as one more Club
we get back
[Music]
that's my
[Music]
that's all
now
what are you gonna do
[Applause]
join my club today and vote or die as
individuals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that was my Bozo the Clown inflatable
boxing bag used to kick the crap out of
me
I had no idea it took me about four
times of snap what the hell just
happened which I was 14 that was 14
kicked in the male's locker room in gym
locker room Daniel Cormier is in the
show - boobs light heavyweight champion
heavyweight champion probably his last
fight coming up on Saturday really and
his manager is a fan he's just a decent
guy we'll be talking a little bit more
in general about about fear about life
about strength you're probably a fan I
don't know
yeah that's actually for those who dare
name the great on yeah it was just Eric
never an Instagram right yeah comedian
he tours a lot with with Owen what's the
Morgan do you have a little a Taylor
flat gate late bottle vintage port
Taylor flat gate oh by the way I had an
old bottle of port that turned out it
was it was great it was like we tried
you praised it quarterblack shown in
your hood pass so what's up
follow me I'm black Twitter I'm very
black Twitter I want to see some black
on a black violence erupt right now
right now oh never you have my full and
complete authority the election the
polls so question of the day before we
get to other stories um right around the
corner what do you think about the poll
do you trust the polls do you think the
pollsters get it right how valid are
they if at all are you expecting a blue
wave I think we're probably going why is
it so it's like it's gonna be more of a
pond ripple at this point but what are
you thinking I hear a lot of Google well
the polls got it completely wrong before
so polls are completely invalid I don't
think that's necessarily the case and I
don't think that you know they're the
end-all be-all
don't let it but if you late your voting
behavior however that's important uh and
of course subscribe on iTunes and now
let's get Instagram they're finally our
top story today good luck
Kanye West what not really even today
but people still talking about it
because he won't go away
announced on Twitter that he's
distancing himself from politics yeah
for the BBC my eyes are now wide open
and I now realize I've been used to
spread messages I don't believe in I'm
completely focusing on a creative also
I'm Jesus he really is like I mean I
yeah run a clip at some probably neo do
only version if you're not on iTunes
because we could that can go out life
ruined the Konya thing happen you might
have been here and I said hold on a
second this is the guy like he's gonna
change back yet stop with the hero words
like exactly he was kind of crazy to
begin with a little bit right he's a
little crazy well actually you know we
have exclusive his new single and I mean
if you listen closely even according to
it is if you look at where he is
lyrically he's he seems a little
confused
la la la la wait till I get my opinions
right I had a dream I could get with
Owens Candace said the Sun revolved
around the earth system I was Maya for
about a second man is so hard not to
change positions don't know what I think
I kind of guessed it hard to know the
truth when you were just the bestest
liberals and mugga then again a liberal
George Bush still don't care about black
people
Alijah keep escaping me even as a baby
mama couldn't get through to me my
sneakers Payless screwing me I'm on
Twitter begging you just to buy him
please I'm just telling you the truth
men ain't completely literate I don't
know how to read man I was poor Trump
till I changed him I guess I didn't get
the acronym
[Applause]
wait till I get my opinions
[Applause]
then you gonna buy my sneakers right
excuse me did you buy my sneakers now
how are you did buy my sneakers we just
wanted to walk out right away and the
mission accomplished right away that
didn't really take a long yeah confused
he got somebody had to be in his here
ear like just are you are you insane
you're gonna realize you know his you
know us no this hair for his sneakers
tanked he wasn't here yet and they were
all what are you talking about sneakers
ya know the Yeezys but I don't know they
were terrible I just want to be the one
on the record saying that all of his
opinions aren't wrong Taylor Swift is
terrible Earth Wind & Fire September and
I've never hated I'll tell you what
Brautigan who works with us is a huge
Taylor Swift fan and he's the kind of
face that black people see in their
nightmares like not live in the Hells
Angels we heard that you kissed a white
girl like I just put a leather three
three piece rocker on I agree with
coming after you I don't I love
Brautigan but really I don't think she's
terrible I love broto and I think it's
weird that he likes pitch perfect in
tech news our organizer to walk out over
an alleged sexual orientations about
Google's protection of employees and it
allegedly engaged in sexual misconduct
the walkout will occur it seems like
this week while the remaining engineers
at Google are planning quote the best
casual Friday ever they seem pretty
[Laughter]
we're gonna get letters oh yes your
comment about the poll that's what
really matters here no it's not the
racist Asian jokes they can take we're
actually able to obtain a cut in
official copy of the women's walks I
think it's the kind of complaints
including some of the alleged of course
the comments and questions that were
made yeah
at Google so we've actually collected
our favorites for this week 7+1 never
forget the one never ever as everyone
here well knows ah seven plus one this
week tops sexual assault comments from
Google employees we know will title it
number seven do you know the difference
between software and hardware dusties
actually bullet let's let's have NIM the
great give us number six let's uh go you
so fine I never ban you for dead naming
[ __ ] so much nicer when he says it
did it really does sound like it you
need more of like a militant black voice
for that yeah exactly like Kanye like on
you three Trump maybe he'll go back to
yeah I don't know
it's kind of like Mike Mike Tyson he was
like well first I want to say I'm very
glad for my sponsor with Wheaties I want
to thank my Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
fast forward two years I want to make
offerings of his children praise be to
Allah don't talk about the fornicating
with you [ __ ] it was a very fast
turnaround one one do you know what the
common denominator was his long there
were five top seven sexual assault
comments at google number five your
google ass looks great in my google
glass it is gonna be like the thing I
want to flip down and have this your
everything yeah yeah no you're thinking
of LeVar Burton and Star Trek which is
understandable that's actually what I
thought open said it was the most design
something that couldn't possibly imagine
being on set with levar burton oh yeah
he must have had an assistant it's just
a seeing eye dog assistant basically
that would suck alright am I on the
spaceship no you're at craft services
well Brad I don't have to take your word
for it
number four people who don't run no
Reading Rainbow I don't care
uh well give name name number four hey
you want to go Star Wars prequel until
that's
prequels number three orange man bad
software engineer penis good that seems
a little bit on the nose a little
derivative I love your mother already
knows that you work on this show it's
okay even I'm taking number two because
[Laughter]
the women's walk women's walk it's
because it was March the walk number two
you should see the Yelp reviews on my
[ __ ] it's mostly four stars but one girl
was a [ __ ] I don't like that one review
after we wrote this was like it should
be Google Place reviews or something so
or what what they bought Zagat something
under the globe well of the Google rot
again were you too busy watching pitch
perfect 19 wait what was the name of
that quite a fan
what's the other one thing Zagat Wow
that's a very common thing it's like it
wasn't before you say it was restaurant
review mag app really that of childhood
really are some cool and you white
people have strange things
well I've sent us ballsy in the internet
area black age you check the Zagat's
like how does agate report on it like
you can never trust the Zagat or it's
pretentious ah actually gonna have G
Morgan you read the number one number
one comments overheard at Google let's
spurred the women's walk I've got a
Google map straight to your heart no say
number one oh give it him do all right
so I'm gonna give number one yeah I've
got a Google map split the difference
[Laughter]
number one I've got a Google map
straight to your heart and the top
Google sexual assault comments were the
opposite led to the women's walk the +1
did you fall out of heaven because I'm
an autistic atheist who really wants to
have sex with you that's been this week
seven plus one Oh
Google I'm holding it right I'm really
scared though that this could backfire
for all the women like it's like they
walk out they just think oh wait this is
the great
work experience and like their stock
just skyrockets and now you have
activity office full of sexist now turns
offenders are incredibly productive look
at her bottom line look rise up [ __ ]
down look in there they're actually
pissed off about something that happened
four years ago so the guy who invented
Android got a big buyout and the claims
were never even substantiated he was he
was supposedly somebody he had sex with
somebody in a hotel room right right got
him to give him a ball right but it was
never both that's the words right and he
just no don't repeat it
Wow your outing me here tonight but
incentive okay so what are you talking
about that they're pissed off over that
it happened in 2014 of the buyout that
any million dollar back off in the mic a
little bit you're giving her a heart
attack because it's like with jail
before show he's like he tests it and
then he I haven't used black voice once
now even better with you because read
him the right I could the hodgetwins II
did not know he did it with me the first
time like I'm proud of you for yesterday
you went the whole episode you didn't do
it that was waiting for you yeah but it
comes from yeah but there's more than
it's the Android thing now this isn't
just about the Android guy so you just
need to verse three total guys but he
was the one they were dry stuff because
he got a buyout yeah so anyway whatever
also because he raped them never
happened before we get to polos before
we get the election the final story of
the day a st. Louis daycare has now been
running a Fight Club ring which was
caught on cameras not exactly USC 230
which Daniel core me will talk about
next but watch the clip a disturbing
sight to kids ring punches on each other
it's being called a Fight Club for kids
by the way if you can be watching that
click that bad mom there is one she's
like an inch away from rolled yelling
out WorldStarHipHop sushis jump and
she's like oh damn oh damn like it's two
o'clock in the morning at a water burger
wait are we offended by this that's like
I don't cuz I got I got at least 60 on
the kid in blue like he kept his elbow
in and I think I think yeah I got you
yeah
well here's the deal like this has
become viral because too many people
have the problem with the obvious kids
beating each other out having watched
the video I'm actually more I'm more
concerned with some of the mental health
of the children in question juice box
Gerald is incredibly confused because I
don't think Gerald's ever seen Fight
Club I I love Fight Club are you kidding
no he's just been he was just disturbed
I was very disturbed he was watching
like anyone else this is all gonna be
rested on me today okay
Gerald writes Android guy was upset
because of but that's it and then like
you're okay Joe that's a good idea
that's like that's it that's all they're
mad about the Android guy or Nimr
or never don't be the Tony Allen for me
none of you none of you and his brothers
no no you did you see the fan that he
had the Minnie Mouse at U of M yeah she
was like I'm Jill oh yeah and girl I
never knew that see that was actually a
test it did happen but it tells me that
G Morgan who doesn't watch the show
which is why is incredible you're
prepared it was on yesterday's show for
those who are Mudd Club members please
worry him that he does not watch the
show okay let's look at the election I
think beforehand I'm not really a
political guy I think actually you
probably are more than I am I know ben
shapiro a bit broad again is brilliant
with this stuff so what are the odds
saying right now for republicans to keep
until the senate it's about a six and
seven chance and then there's a one in
seven chance that republicans keep
control of the house okay so very likely
that democrats take control out this is
that being said i think democrats are
gonna be surprised I don't know anyone
else has any opinions on this or if I'm
gonna be resting here by myself
I hope so jerk I definitely have
opinions on this I don't think I think
because of the Cavanaugh thing that
we're probably going to see a lot more
people that are Republicans do better or
win but I'm worried that it happened so
long ago in political time right first
reason we forget stuff after about a
week yeah and so we need something
usually has to happen within the last
week of the election to get people out
to the polls right yeah and I don't I
don't know if that carryovers gonna
happen I'm gonna get her done flag on a
bomb outside of an envelope doesn't do
it so that's not a needle mover maybe
something else you know I think I think
they're probably going to win the house
I do think it's Rob it but by a very
very slim margin I think the blue wave
if you're expecting a giant blue wave I
think they'll be surprised that's
entirely conjecture Eric what sir what
so they'll be like bipartisan movements
and working in Congress will become
effective it's far easier to be a cynic
than to tell us how you really feel
exactly it's just like this lunch sucks
rather than tell everyone in a school
cafeteria that you're hurting inside
sorry I didn't go that's what that Zagat
is a grading system it really doesn't
know it's not a restaurant it's a rave
like it was Yelp before Yelp was a thing
I just feel like it's a slur that you
guys got away with no it is a bi-racial
gay smell it was real so wait I would be
by the way also Saget's have to be
incredibly unfunny apparently funny
accident
there was his first special wasn't
horrible okay now so nice he got money
it just destroyed him I think all the
political stuff he does sucks I just
think he's not funny
I thought Jon Stewart was brilliant very
funny yeah yeah he said but I really
they also don't find Chris Rock funny I
think Richard Pryor Eddie Murphy I just
don't find Chris I feel like I'm told to
like Chris rile yeah I agree that I
don't know how accurate these
predictions going into the midterms okay
polls are sketchy and some people trust
Mo's reliable and some people completely
throw them out that we talked about
earlier it's not fair to say that polls
are always wrong neither of those
positions are correct but I think this
is very important because the left wants
you to do this you certainly shouldn't
base your voting habits on polls you
shouldn't allow will talk about mental
strength mental fortitude with Daniel
Cormier who had to overcome some serious
adversity in his life um they do sort of
it's it's the it's the world war two
propaganda you know
you have only lasts a while right that's
what the left is trying to do and I
think they try to do with Trump and all
of a sudden the national polls closed
quite a bit with Trump national about 1
they gave him 99 99 percent chance at
Hillary Clinton would win a national
election you know you were with me that
night our entire election stream was
just tuning into the young turks and
watching the new york times odds never
so I have a legitimate question for you
what why do we even have polls in the
first place I mean I hear and here's the
me let me frame the question a little
bit polls affect how you vote like you
just said if you're gonna in a place
like where you're voting for somebody
who's gonna win running away then you're
probably not gonna go vote or maybe
you're on the fence and you're not gonna
go out right and so if the poll says are
gonna run away you're gonna stay home so
I don't know that I even like polls
before the election anyway see I
disagree I don't know what their purpose
their purpose is for people obviously
there should be polls for people who are
running for office
I understand they do all the time yeah
here's the thing I don't care because if
someone is is that easily influenced
then then there's an 88 who's probably I
couldn't I know but that's the majority
of the electorate unfortunate no it's
not that's not you know that's that's
actually why polls are an algorithm no
no there's a go the truth is that's why
polls are inaccurate very often is that
they don't necessarily they're not there
isn't a good mechanism there aren't
effective metrics in place to measure
voter enthusiasm right so we will talk I
think we have a source later from from
Fox the young people lean overwhelmingly
left they don't vote is the same thing
with black people
except for Obama it's the same that it's
why they weren't able to measure Donald
Trump they don't measure son they don't
have a metric to sort of test
enthusiastic voting basis who really are
a quiet majority sometimes so that is
why they get it wrong and I think that's
important and I do think that they try
to manipulate that by putting out these
polls as doomsday scenario because they
actually want to manipulate public
opinion but I want them to try because
it's even sweeter black people not
voting this time around like I like it
first so you should be like what we
should get out there and then I was on
Twitter yes like wait so if you come out
as a Republican CNN calls you a [ __ ] yes
you come out as a Democrat they say
on a plantation either way its own a
plantation I don't know what see no I
mean I like Twitter like it you're just
a slave on the page you were like two
people who say that no that's the
argument Candace oh it says that
yeah she says like a Puritan I give you
vote Democrat you're just owning the
plantation I was like wait so I'm a
Cohen for that the difference is the
Democratic Party tells of the you're a
traitor and not black enough if the
Republican Party doesn't say you're on
the plantation yeah that's one person
does no the Democratic Party actually
you know they always say not black
enough mommy will not apparently there's
more black to Nimr because she says hot
sighs let's go through just a few
polling debacles that come to mind there
are three but two we'll just kind of
said their mothers club wrecks it he
were way off yes they're trying to do
right now correct it screw them against
Bernie Sanders as much as I don't like
him I think he's crazy
I'm not talking about when I primary
against Hillary Clinton because she had
more money than God I'm pretty sure that
God calls her pollutants like ring-ring
I you know I don't like making this call
[Laughter]
paying for it to men she was absolutely
gonna be the president national polls
but if they were very very inaccurate
Bernie Sanders in a lot of for example
up Michigan where Bianchi went you saw
journey for Bernie and I think Clinton
had a 99% chance of winning it's 90
something percent chance of winning she
can and Bernie won handily yeah so they
got that kind of lately wrong and Bernie
was like yes socialist Maria I love that
[Music]
if you're watching this you're saying
you want more of it louder come smoke
with me to seven day free trial we can't
continue this show without you joining
Mudd Club course on YouTube because of
the overlords and we're not sponsored by
farmers dog even though
/ Itza no idea why no idea why and then
of course the number one polling this is
the Trump selection yes almost all of
the polls got this completely wrong and
I will say this I I thought that he was
going to lose remember before this I
said well I said listen don't ask me
because if someone like Thomas so loved
Charles Krauthammer rest in peace at
that point and even Dick Morris I mean
between you know it's the guy massages
got it wrong I am NOT the guy who's
going to get elections right so I'll
offer you my opinion on what I think
regarding starting candidates when it
came to the election I said I think it's
probably a 60/40 chance Hillary wins
yeah I didn't say 99% like the New York
Times but I did puts more trust in the
polls and I learned a lesson yeah so
when we were doing that show I was
actually preparing myself to talk about
Hillary Clinton in some kind of light as
the winner like I knew she refilling to
win really the most we prepared in
Oscars accepted what Meryl Streep and
then we're over there and I'm like oh my
gosh this is actually happening I can't
believe this and the best part and I'm
sorry I know this makes me a bad person
to some degree is when they showed
people at her campaign celebration
headquarters whatever crime but yes not
only that not he said he came in really
closer to know where's my microphone
[Music]
you're not that bold the worst part
Clinton - back then when were talking
about strength the strength of character
been talk about that quite a bit
trotting someone else out for the
concession speech remember yeah you show
up she's like how did this happen I know
well she was passed out but she was like
Jeff just take the baguette pans like
every time is like she was just
backstage in a cotton um I think she's
that crazy so it comes down to why we're
all the polls wrong and then I'll get
into what they're doing with these polls
now because the blue wave isn't going to
be as big of a blue wave as they thought
I hate that I have to get I hate in
Micra this is actually that
we were thinking of doing a live
election strip we might say to let me
know if you want us to do it it's just
going to be so boring like national
elections are interesting because of the
cultural ramifications but yeah like Ted
Cruz is going to absolutely just Merc
bado or really it's not even gonna be
close so outside of that there isn't
really a whole lot that interests me how
do they get it wrong again they were
right about general opinions these polls
it's hard to predict who actually
hotel-like the likely voters thing
Romney actually I think they had him
winning or was it was really close but
Election Day but fewer people the that
the cavalry didn't come over the hill
for Romney less so than even McCain if
you can believe it that's because Romney
shut it down in the second debate after
he killed Obama in the first one he I
was it didn't energize your face after
that no he didn't he was the only one
who went after I went after Obama on the
first destroyed him in the first and he
just stepped back because I wanted to
play a nice guy and then you know people
like Bernie or Trump who can energize a
vote voting basically said who typically
wouldn't vote and that's true I don't
know if it culturally is a black person
if you have most of your family members
and friends voted oh yeah my mother well
most of black women black women don't
get it's kind of like going to church
like they'll be the ones but like you
better do it nobody else like so it's
kind of emblematic it's like the women
are like hey let's do this is the right
thing and then when it comes time to
actually do it the oh I was just about
to be proud of you for using the word
Merc I was like oh he used it like it's
like you have black friends I was proud
of yeah it's a gaming term I thought it
came from gaming Merc Timur yes it's a
Black Knight Li Hao show to mercs who
might like to murder out something like
a hip hop thing no no we stole it we
appropriated it sorry all right
so this is about like for example except
black people often don't vote they came
on they voted quite a bit for Barack
Obama yeah young people typically a lean
very left it's it's a lock generation Z
like I've talked about you can search on
this channel
not so much there's still more liberal
but you can count on them getting very
concerned as they get older because
they're more conservative at this point
in their life than even Gen Xers or
certainly Millennials but they just
don't vote we have a source I think here
from box so the question is how do you
get them to turn out young people
specifically right is what happens from
the left or actually speed it P Diddy I
don't was he P Diddy was he Puff Daddy
at that I don't know if you
as he did he did he now uh he's a
brother love now Rio I swear I guess are
you screwing with me now I'm serious his
brother loves when did this happen
uh like ago yeah yes about a year
year-and-a-half time like that yeah
isn't that from the Nutty Professor
bloody love buddy love but thanks for
playing all right you know what he's
it's I bet you he probably set
he was watching The Nutty Professor with
anywhere he's like me there you go I
wish I had a name like buddy love
actually knowing I know brother love did
you see the story that made him do it
like yeah you shoot someone in a
nightclub worse actually he took a he
went to his kid plays football for UCLA
and the coach was yelling at his kid too
much so he took a cowbell and smacked
the coat inside the head really was
getting charges and all these things
came out he was like call me brother
love I'm actually peace-loving happy oh
that really kind of like Metta World
Peace well it's a punch out fans
yeah well it's um more cowbell yeah I
get you I don't think he was that clever
I think he was like I'm just gonna grab
any bill I possibly can and hit him and
look I change it on my license II can't
get me like no we still can I don't
think you know it works so they're
trying to get the youth vote PVD did the
rock to vote campaign remember back then
it was I think it was George Bush versus
John Kerry and Cameron Diaz was on Oprah
and she said if you don't vote guys it's
like saying you want rape to be legal
even Oprah was like
I know it's gonna happen a minister my
own network it's gonna fail in height
re-enter beta or work they're pulling on
every single stop in the book right now
to try and get young people to vote
here's your just like there's like
literally putting him on a skateboard
kid I am I'm gonna kick flip my way into
office but you don't ever take my word
for it where's the mic oh I don't know
here's one that's really really shame
fatal Beto's have you seen this I can't
really go the YMCA dance if the
pandering doesn't even work like what a
kid's like I know a washed-up gay cover
band in the Village People
that's what they like I don't know
should be something like should it be
something like Drake or sir no I'm
pretty sure we're gonna go with the
Village People who wants to deal with
that gay S&M Folsom Street Village
person that one doesn't really make
sense that's for us more so that's for
afterparty
it was not even one person accidentally
on beatnik like that's the most
mayonnaise video I've ever seen in my
life
oh no really you think so you think so
all right hold your tongue sir because
let's go to the next clip
it must be real feel none parity is he a
head of Tedros yet
[Music]
we get them internships at Google not
worse than the earlier clearness I was
like oh glad that you said it's so
terribly that's not real that's real
yeah we say you are just out of touch
with the youth don't be fooled because
black don't crack this man is a hot he's
not young enough I know what the kids
are into
they're into this wait that was MPEG
that's not real Ted Cruz bought that
that was very fun this part but Ted Cruz
is hiring all of his it's like a best
day all right now it's very important
very important that you misses the high
note and I want this to appear too I
wanted to take place in a subdivision
with no tree so it's very clear that
they had no budget not ironically but
truthfully and all white people I really
think I'm really like I'm not a
conspiracy guy but I think Ted Cruz's
campaign has been texting my phone under
vetoes now it's doing like in shooting
all of these come out like all of this
is to because nobody would do that to
themselves uh well it wouldn't work
because here look elections
unfortunately become a beauty contest in
the United States right instead of
looking at the skills that somebody has
or their abilities come on you know I'm
pissed
what beauty contest is Donald Trump
winning he's judging them through a
one-way mirror I think they are beauty
and what let me just say this way Donald
Trump rally to base of people that was
mad 15 years ago 20 years ago Donald
Trump stood no chance you had to rile up
an entire base of people first for that
to happen Barack Obama did the exact
same thing basically went out and said
what everybody wanted to hear I'm gonna
heal the nation I'm gonna take us in the
right direction didn't have the ability
to do any of it and screwed it up we are
not looking for the best qualified
candidate we're looking for somebody
that makes us feel good and that sucks
because politicians will always make you
feel good they're always gonna say like
their job here I think that's true to a
large degree but not entirely you don't
you don't feel better after the Village
People in I'm gonna make a prediction
right now Stephen you're right betas
gonna lose and right after that they're
gonna try to get him to run for 2020 not
only is he going to lose
this race and suck at it royally and I
can guarantee you won't win in 2020 you
know what because I'm gonna interview
him as a [ __ ] like Wendy you have to
but that's exactly what they're gonna do
they're like this guy's got it we
watched your video in the suburb it was
great by the way
people haven't seen the women's March
video where Stephanie interviewed Wendy
Davis I never expected that to happen it
was all so we just go ask what he does
have an interview and then they and then
my wig blows off with the wind mid
interview bury siege think it's totally
it's totally fine it's told like oh my
gosh you were never gonna make out
you're never gonna be an office again
and by the way I'm very familiar with
the pandering not just for the youth
vote but as we know from my um here's
the thing I hate to just bash Canada I
wish I were more proud of Canada than I
am but you want to talk about pandering
getting it's a niche vote but it's
important about the Indian vote let's
look at the prime minister of my former
home country
it's like I mean you thought of black
he's not a white guy trying to a black
dance is embarrassing somehow made it
even wider to do bars pretty low though
watching that made me want to put on a
diaper and go on a starvation diet like
that
we gotta get white people out Indian
culture diaper if you're on a starvation
diet tell that to Gandhi
I don't think Gandhi thought ahead
really I just think Gandhi had a lot of
followers that were it was on it was
unwarranted he would have worn invest
all right so here's a here's a point
Paul I went to get the Daniel Cormier
poles are often wrong okay and more
importanly they're not the end-all
they're not the be all poles there
seeing this big blue wave that's what
the meet here's the thing it could be
true but it's certainly what the media
wants you to think they could have
believed beforehand that Donald Trump
was going to win I was going to lose was
at Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania all I
actually said I think he wins
Pennsylvania and Ohio I remember I was
like I think there's no way he wins
Michigan and this is because in Michigan
yeah I knew too many people in Michigan
and it's but the truth is he appealed to
a lot of the Union voters who probably
my Western Miss you might want to
support Trump this next go-around yeah
so I said no Michigan I think he wins
Pennsylvania Ohio if you go back and
look at it they said there's no way he
wouldn't Michigan Wisconsin Ohio
Pennsylvania they said he doesn't want
anything in the Midwest and he went
office so they could have actually
thought that but we know for certain
that it is what they wanted and it's
what they wanted you to believe and it's
what they wanted everyone in Michigan to
believe and in Pennsylvania to believe
and right now they may believe that
there's this big blue wave coming or
they may not what we do know is that
they want you to believe it to stay home
and not vote and that's why you see the
desperate pandering for votes and by the
way here's one thing to a very unpopular
position that I hold tweet me if you
disagree I really don't care
I hate get out to vote campaigns I hate
them I can't stand them if if Kanye West
is at home and someone makes it through
the gates and says excuse me sir have
you thought about voting this election
now you see I'm Jesus I'm a vote now
because you rang my doorbell if that's
what if that's true
why you voting at home I don't want
people who are uninformed to vote I
don't know there's nothing there's
nothing virtuous in voting voting is not
the voting is not the end-all be-all
itself it's it's it's a means to an end
and the left just wants any person they
can load up onto a bus and give a free
sandwich to vote to vote I don't want
you voting people who do not understand
the Constitution
you probably shouldn't vote people who
do not it be like playing fantasy
football and you have no I be like me
pulling fantasy football I don't put it
because I know I'd lose sure I might
roll the dice and get it right but
that's not how you're supposed to play
it with a constitutional republic
regardless of what Don Lemon Anderson
Cooper Kanye West or Drake the
butter-soft [ __ ] from Toronto who I
don't even think we vote but try
cellphone Memphis tells you if you don't
keep yourself abreast of all the issues
if you're not informed stay home don't
vote I don't want you determining the
fate of our country we have Daniel
Cormier coming up next hopefully he did
he was he was late he missed last time I
have a bonafide with
[Music]
I'm sure a lot of you feel out of place
like Jamie Foxx third string quarterback
five foot six or Dennis Quaid who at the
time of filming is literally 55 years
you know you're weak but you're not weak
when you're joined together with other
members of Mudd Club some of whom have
great big asses largely irrelevant join
my club today and vote or die as
individuals
[Music]
all right gotta be cute maddie is
standing in the corner there she wants
to know just go to your go to your goes
to cute Maddy
our next guest I'm really happy now
who's that there on your TV DC it's
still a horrible nickname I maintain but
you can follow him of course DC
underscore MMA he is fighting against
Derrick Lewis whose nickname I'm not
allowed to say as a what no I'm not do
you think that's just a gay okay well
for Daniel Cormier for people very
thanks for being back sir thank you for
having me again man I appreciate it yeah
especially after you stiffed us the last
time if you were not the baddest man in
the planet I would be upset you could be
upset but instead of Crowder confront it
would be Cormier confronts Crowder yeah
it'd be more like corny beats Crowder's
ass if it curls up in the fetal position
no you don't mind is IDIA logically
confronting and yours is you know you
beat people up but you're you're a sharp
guy so maybe you can answer this Derrick
Lewis well he goes with the black beast
is that just a gag on white people so if
we say it like in the wrong restaurant
we get our asses kicked see it's like
it's like if they're it Lewis walked in
and you guys won the black beast the
black beast the black piece it just kind
of gives them an out to just start being
people's ass Derek wants to reserve the
right to just beat people up and so he
gave himself that nickname but it is a
nickname where it's almost like should I
say it should I not say yes what it all
deals you know yeah and if you're
Pappajohn you just scream out the n-word
on a conference call you're like yeah I
don't know what happened there why would
you do that Papa John um actually by the
way what he was quoting someone else who
said it and still he's no longer Papa
Johnson
no man do it do it you don't need Papa
John's anymore I'm there I never really
was a big fan of it the dough is a
little bit too thick okay there's a food
that I don't like you know you've got
some problems you're more of a New York
style pizza guy not not a deep-dish um
yes I like it a little dinner
do you not what you know your nickname
is DC like you said which is really just
an initial are you upset at all that you
didn't take the black piece beforehand
you know sometimes guys just aren't
creative you know I'm not the most
creative guy I'm gonna go ahead and
stick my headphones in Steve just so I
can hear you a little bit better well I
can't tell you any differently because
you're you know
now I can really hear you okay um I wish
I would have did a better job for
picking my nickname but here's the deal
I went to school at Oklahoma State and
at Oklahoma State they don't do the best
job of choosing nicknames they're not
very creative right though they're the
ones that started calling me DC first
and they're just kind of stuck I had
never been called DC until I was in
Oklahoma cuz coach Smith started saying
it all the time and everybody else just
kind of picked up on it yeah and this is
by the way an opponent I want to say
four people and we'll get into more kind
of macro issues as well everyone here's
one thing everyone else on the planet
would be terrified to fight Derek Lewis
right you're strong you're strongly
favored you're expected to beat him yeah
I know you've talked about before how
being an underdog really drives you you
know for example going back in with John
Jones that was just a legendary rivalry
does it ever worry you a little bit that
people are kind of expecting this to be
just a walk through for you you know I I
just I think it's on me to make sure
that I prepare myself to the best of my
ability right I can't let the odds
dictate how I approach the fight I've
been a favorite before I mean I was -
1100 versus Patrick Cummins I was - 900
against Dan Henderson he was one of the
greatest mixed martial artists of all
time
right I was still able to implement my
game plan and fight him in the way that
I wanted cause they also found for
people who didn't see those fights you
rag-dolled both of them it wasn't even
close that's why I wonder if you're like
oh man at sooner or later I'm rolling
that time times up because you did Dan
Henderson I'm no disrespect to any of
them it wasn't even close you know it I
know it so is there's that little bit of
you know as a victor where you're a
little worried like I mean I don't want
to get overconfident at some point I'm
worried that is it gonna be me at some
point where the guy throwing me around
like that I will never say I will never
say I ragdoll I leave that for you to
say you ragdoll it so literally picking
up and I love Dan Anderson for those who
don't know he picked him up watch that
any went and it looked like an athlete
cartoon where were just like when it's
double weeds people it was it was very
very effective it was bad it was it was
one of my better performances but my
whole deal is this right Dan Henderson's
not a guy you truly want to mess with I
messed with him in the confines of the
Octagon right
I would prefer him to approach you just
in random environment instead of me so
I'm not gonna sit here and say Dan's an
avid hunter he knows how to shoot a bow
and arrow
this guy is a true true bad man so
there's no TN hey Dan I love you believe
I know I know listen I like the one over
here talking crazy no I'm not I would
love that dead-enders another Shelby
like Bob I remember back in the day when
he was in primes like man I would love
to see those super fights and a
everyone's talking about Wanderlei Chuck
I was like no no I really want to see
Dan Henderson come over he was the man
at that point rich man remember and I
was like yeah Dan Henderson really and I
like Rich Franklin that was the man he
was yeah he's but you know gave the man
you ragdoll them okay so someone who
obviously everyone else would be afraid
of did you do anything speaking of which
too spooky for Halloween what did you do
for Halloween we I have my kids and my
wife here so we went to one of my
friends has a nice apartment in town
what he had like I don't know 600
apartments but they listed all the ones
that were giving out trick or treats and
we went to these doors up and down
floors my kids wanted to hit everyone
which was absolutely impossible so he
went to a few and then we went to the
gym and the guy that was working the gym
was kind of like oh my god oh my god oh
my god DC DC DC so then he just stuck
his hand in the candy bin grabbed as
much candy as you can grab he just threw
it in my kid's bag and I was like okay
guys what I really learned from that
story is that the the person at the
front desk of the gym was gay that's
what I learned for that you might not
even realize it you know what it's like
actually my friend Gerald was in here he
doesn't realize when he talks with black
people he does a black guy voice have
you ever found of those people or she's
always like oh man don't don't even
mention it Roy like what the hell are
you doing you're some chicken entity so
yeah okay okay Jim Raynor okay so we're
talking was it gay stop them
let me ask you this any plant I believe
in a closed ballot a box are you
planning on voting coming up this these
elections uh yes I honestly
honestly it there there's some elections
coming up like very very soon right but
I've been so busy worrying about the
fight and I've really paid attention to
much so yeah uh so that's all why is it
all about it that's yes life is all
about it that's that's good did not sit
where's a lot of people like man I
haven't been paying attention I'm gonna
be first in line two votes like okay you
know what hold back a little bit I did
have this question because obviously you
know khabib recently had as his scuffles
to put it that that way and you know you
work for it with a company the UFC Dana
White you know came out publicly
endorsed President Trump and khabib
obviously not a big fan you managed to
really stay out of the fray as a
customer who's on TV constantly as a
commentator are you ever put in the
middle of that at all or is just
something you just carte blanche don't I
don't I don't touch it you know I just
don't touch it because the reality is
there is no winning right there really
is no winning either you're all you're
here are you're there and I just would
rather not be involved because then it
doesn't isolate me from here or it
doesn't isolate me from here right and
so I just kind of stay away from it like
I really don't like my views and my
thoughts are my views and my thoughts
and I don't need to uh I don't need to
really share them you know and if you
express one you could have Dana White
mad at you and if you express the other
khabib x' entire troupe of dagestan use
will stomp you into the everybody I mean
it's just there's no winning there's no
winning with that no never let me ask
this we've been talking about this kind
of as it relates to the current climate
a lot of people talk about being afraid
on e on all sides like you said well as
the baddest man on the planet you know
it's kind of this is what's obviously
bestowed upon the heavyweight champion
and light heavyweight champion um what
what is Daniel Cormier what do you fear
what like genuinely what scares you the
most like Brazilian Wandering Spider
notwithstanding that's at the top of all
ours yeah but you know I mean I think my
fears are as the same as everybody I
mean honestly we came to New York City
on Sunday for the fight and I was just
Halloween you know there's a reason we
went to my friend Jimmy's apartment
because it's terrified to be out on the
street nowadays with your children and I
think that's my biggest fear my wife was
talking to me about going to a parade
I was just like man I don't know if I
want my children in a very densely
populated place and crowded because that
seems to be the time that people want to
do the craziest things yeah and I was
like man let's try to do something safer
like my biggest fear is that something
happens with my children I mean all
these horrible horrible things that are
going on almost daily now I just want to
try to shield them my kids and my wife
from as much as possible so that's what
scares me and that's honestly I'm some
very safe Steve like I don't I don't
really go many places with big crowds
after all concerts basketball games
football games as much as I would love
to go watch the Saints play every week
or Oklahoma State I really don't because
there's always that that underlying fear
that uh things are so crazy right now in
the world you know what that's something
I I've had to deal with a lot obviously
I'm not as famous as Daniel Cormier but
um especially with what I do you know
listen sometimes gonna be more
polarizing and III I'm curious as to
what how you balance the idea of sort of
either paranoia or anxiety in public
places versus a legitimate healthy fear
I had tickets to Tom Jones I know Tom
Jones and Alice Cooper and I missed both
concerts because I I got to a certain
point where I said you know what I just
don't want it to be a powder keg with my
wife and to everyone else who doesn't
really understand it it's a different
kind of problem that you're into like I
would stop being paranoid how do you
balance okay this is a healthy fear
versus maybe I'm blowing this out of
proportion I think I think safer is
better like that's just kind of my my
idea like I rather err on the side of
safety then take a chance and risk in it
and and and then ultimately it costs you
something that's so terrible that you
really can't bounce back from right you
know when you when you say you missed
the Tom Jones concert well you missed
the concert but at the end of the day
you still have your wife and you guys
didn't run into any issues and those are
the things that really matter man it's
like you just can't this it's like you
just when you live in the public eye
especially as you are right because
you're very vocal about your beliefs
whereas I just kind of stayed state to
state clear right your vocal so I mean
there are gonna be a certain there are
we certain people that truly even want
to hurt you or people that truly support
you sometimes your supporters are very
dangerous because they kind of crowd you
you ever had you ever been hurt have you
ever been hurt by fans actually had a
finger jammed really badly once by a guy
reached out there and it jammed my ring
finger like hard you ever had something
like that happen well just grab it right
like people look grab you right you'll
be walking somewhere and people will
grab you and they'll grab you and I mean
it's just scary expressing my kids there
on TV a lot and even the other day we're
in New York City and my wife is walking
down the street with my children holding
them each on the one side took him to
Dave & Buster's and she said as she's
walking down the street a guy starts
walking towards her gets down on his
knees and starts to open his arms like
he's gonna hug my son and I always make
fun of my wife about when I'm at home I
kind of hide in crevices and she walks
on that just laughs and it instantly
freezes every single time okay I said
well what happens if you're in public
and somebody does that she goes I'll
probably freeze up so when she told me
the story I laughed she goes did you
laugh I said yes because when the guy
went down to hug my son was it wasn't
Jimmy out you ran no it was some guy on
ok it was a guy walking the street he
went to hug my kid and see y'all don't
you touch him and she kind of kicked him
and I hope I laughed because you did not
freeze right you instantly protected our
kids she was like don't you ever touch
him and she told Daniel don't let anyone
touch you yeah because people see them
in the public too and for her who she
don't really choose our public life
right I read someone that has a public
life it's uh it's her and our kids have
to kind of live that way q yeah so I
mean that's a real thing and it's scary
good for her though you know what I
think I think you do get a little more
lice I don't know if you feel this way
for example we just this we did this big
show at U of M you know and thousands of
people showed up in there was this after
party afterward and there was a there
was a guy from Michigan State sitting
down who just started really trying to
start a fight I was there I was I was
base but my friend was Liberace for
Halloween Owen Benjamin he's a pianist
he's six foot seven to eight he's a
giant so he stands out the big pink
rhinestone I'm an ass less chaps
and short shorts he's like so you want
you like an effing gay cowboy said yeah
man I guess so
hey kept trying to go on for a fight and
he was he was an african-american
gentleman and obviously people right now
with their attentions I was like I don't
want to get into a fight with this guy
because of the liability now that being
said if this guy were shoving someone
like my wife because he did get a little
bit pushy physically I think I'd
probably go berserk it's probably you
were licensed like your wife maybe
freezes when it's her but with her
children that mama bear hasn't kicks in
it kicks in and I'm happy it did you
know and she told my my son even don't
let anybody hug you like yeah you don't
have to take pictures if you don't want
to you don't have to let anyone hug you
you know just because that's not that's
not part of the deal you know they're
just two kids with their mom trying to
enjoy New York City yeah that is creepy
that's really creepy again sorry kids I
mean I'm okay I get awkward with like
kids I know like my friends and their
kids are there and like you know like my
friend Johnny boy producer his daughter
has a major crush me she's like I'm
gonna marry you I'm like oh that's sweet
she's like no look at me look at your
everything I've ever dreamed of to make
it more awkward I turn to Johnny bland I
go John
I would never ever take advantage from
just so you know get your daughter a job
get your daughter yeah she's very she is
very very aggressive at a young age so
you did last time I think even when she
spoke about this that you were planning
on hanging up your gloves I think your
your birthday in March your 40th
birthday yes
ah and you you're not only broadcasting
with MMA but I know you've talked about
branching out into other sports you're
just you're just a good commentator in
general I think you break the mold of
what a lot of people think of what a lot
of people think of it fighters they
think of something in their minds eye
that is the black beast let's be honest
yeah oh he's got that nickname so you
have a career foot in broadcasting are
you hanging up the gloves still March
are you is that is that set in stone
yeah the day that's no the same I'm not
I'm looking to fight this time and then
hopefully fight Brock Lesnar beginning
in the next year and then that'll
probably be it I mean I
just don't want to be that guy that goes
off on his back man we've seen so many
of our great champions that had all
these shining examples these moments
that are etched in our minds forever but
they stay too long in my time it's over
they're getting beat by people they
never would have gotten beat before so
um it's I don't want to be that guy I
wanna I want to leave people with the
memories that IIIi have had up to this
point you know a case in point right now
we've got Chuck Liddell find T Ortiz I
mean yeah those guys aren't broke
they're not broke guys like people think
these guys are fighting for money
they're not broke they don't fight
because they still think they can fight
I just wish my memories of Chuck what's
staying him in the Octagon just going
crazy right where Tito Ortiz doing the
grave digger thing you know but it's
like they're fighting each other and one
of them has to lose right and that will
be something that will be stuck in your
mind I didn't few chocolate del and you
lose this fight you're up 2-0 yeah one
of the greatest rivalries in the sports
history you go and give this guy the
last one it's like it doesn't make any
sense to me it's it's it's no Rini one
two fights and then you know who knows
what Tito is doing over there
who knows what anyone's doing over there
in Bellator let's be honest baby walking
here in Bellator they're fighting for
Golden Boy Promotions Oscar De La Hoya
is promoting the fight on pay-per-view
and I mean I love Chuck you know I think
tal is a great guy too I just I just
work I worry about what happens on that
night ya know I think you're I think I
think you're right let me ask this you
see you were really tense at one point
in your career I think kind of in that
that period were you've talked about how
you really feel you had something to
prove and you really didn't like John
Jones then you couldn't get back at him
because of all the drug controversies we
seem to see you're relaxed really happy
Daniel Cormier Lee I know you're
generally a are seen as an affable guy
but today it's noticeable let me ask you
is is there some kind of a corner you've
turned or just because you keep winning
like do you think that you can mean
misdemeanor
I know FBI gone some do you think you
can maintain this two meter and this
calmness if you were to lose or do you
think it's just victory makes you so
know just who I am and also Stephen me
not having to cut all the way
yeah and I wasn't seeing I was just up
there stop that's better right does that
take off some of that light off my face
you look gorgeous either way yeah you
look good I'm Jim managering out here oh
okay you look great in the way Thank You
faceless man for helping that's Bob
thank you that's Bob I know I'm sure it
helps but you do seem much more relaxed
to rephrase it but you see more ways
then what was that always it's not
cutting all the weight you don't find up
at heavy weight now so I'm not losing 45
pounds to get to the fight you know I
mean and also just really being content
with everything that I've accomplished
in this sport I mean win or lose this
weekend which I won't you can't take
away what happened in July right those
images of me with two belts will always
remain the same it's true and I think
there's a comfort in that there's a
comfort in the accomplishment and I know
that even though I'm comfortable in the
accomplishment I'm not ready to let it
go but I am Who I am and that'll never
change people can't take anything away
from me anymore well I I'm really glad
to hear that and I'm sad to hear that
you're hanging them up just make sure
two things promise me two things you're
not just gonna gain a ton of weight and
be a walking coronary like a lot of
previous a lineman and football that you
know you healthy and don't get in a
propeller plane we saw how that ended
with Rocky Marciano we don't alou's you
to an elm tree never okay and final
those are two things you don't have to
worry about good okay okay okay okay
I gotta be careful with eating too much
that's one thing I gotta be careful with
but I gotta be on TV for the rest of my
life so I gotta maintain at least some
sort of you know this beauty that I have
with my face look at that I've got my
teeth pick Steve look at that now did
you wait because you know hockey players
don't get their teeth fixed because we
said we talked about crazy fighting as
hockey players back in the day enforcers
would have 40 fights in a season they
have to get right back in the ice they
just never fixed their teeth until the
end of their careers was that a
conscious decision for you yeah it was
time you know I started to do more
things like your show and more like more
national things outside of mixed martial
arts and there was an idea or a way you
need to present yourself when you're
doing that and it was time taken I've
done it a long time
and I also knew that you know as I get
closer you know it's time to get it done
I put it off put it off it off because
if this thing gets knocked out Saturday
I just go get it fixed again right I
only have one more fight but five six
years ago I had 13 more fights and if it
was getting knocked out every single
time it really didn't benefit me so yeah
it was just time to get it done but was
it tough like debris you ever
self-conscious about it during that time
like really I mean I just kind of became
who I was you know I've always had like
partials that I could stick in oh it's
just told not to I always had things
that I could like put on my hood like a
retainer and all this but I just chose
not to I I was always comfortable with
who I am well you're a bold man and
you're braver than I am because I get
really pissed about all these gray hairs
that I have thirty-one going on
chemistry
captain fantastic it's like you should
just ferment it like you're supposed to
support me as I become a silver five you
are just any one thing man the guy the
guy that has Gloria's hair like you and
it's all silver I think that's a winner
makes you look distinguished exactly
well thank you but it's no I have no I
don't care that you can kick my ass but
you can grab me by my still brown hair
no I'm gonna let it go gray I'm not
gonna do the worst is when someone goes
gray and then they dye it like they
don't do the gradual dye we had a
passenger go in one day and it was
bloody was bright blonde I'm like
everyone is watching me right now going
we saw you yesterday at this - yeah come
on dude
final question obviously the fight I
want to make sure is a black base Derek
Lewis it is happening November second
UFC 230 let me ask you this we were
talking about this we had bombers what'd
I say did I say second sorry my second
that's Friday Friday the second started
wins the third is the actual fight from
Madison Square Garden I am terrible with
numbers fights are always Saturday
unless I think sometimes if they're in
different countries time zones let's not
get to yes it's November third UFC 230
we had Buster on the show the other day
and I was talking about you know his
serious neck injury that he had had at
one point I know how familiar you are
with it but for him it was a real
struggle to start even moving you know
five pounds and and and now he's back to
basically full ability we talk a lot on
this show about about
strength and there's this idea I think
this false idea of machismo and it's
often associated with fighters and I
used bra I used bas Rutten as an example
because for him he was weak as a kitten
with one arm after the neck injury but
he was strong because he said okay I'm
gonna get passed I'm gonna push past
this and eventually he got back to where
he was whereas a lot of people just
don't push past that discomfort to
Daniel Cormier best fighter in the face
of the planet right now before you leave
how do you define strength what do you
think matters most particularly for a
lot of young men listening I like the
mental you know honestly man and and I
think and this might be like Oh we'd
only hear this about fight promotion but
I think strength to me honestly is
defined by a guy like Derek Lewis
you know when Derrick Rose was a team he
left Louisiana down to Texas and got in
a ton of trouble ended up in prison now
you know that when you go to prison
there are guys in there every night
saying what they're gonna do when they
get out and how they're gonna be better
when they get out and they'll never go
back and I'm gonna make a life for my
family and they write these notes and
they do all these things as to how life
is going to improve but then they end up
back in prison pursuit of them right
right right yeah recidivism rate is
through the roof
Derek lose never went back Derek Lewis
became a millionaire
Derek Lewis is fighting for the
heavyweight championship of the world
that's why would people say he knocked
that guy out with ten seconds I'm like
10 seconds that that doesn't surprise me
because this man fought from the pits of
hell to build himself back up to this
point yeah to me that strength
right when you are dealt with
unbelievable adversity and in the face
of that adversity you don't crumble you
try to build back when I lost my
daughter and life tried to knock me down
and put me out for the count I tried to
rebuild myself when a person goes
through these terrible tragedies that
are going on today the families of these
people that are dying in these mass
shootings are dying when someone decides
to drive their car into a crowd of
people these families that scrape
themselves off the ground and rebuild
that strength
you know when you're dealt unbelievable
adversity and you come through it and
become better for it that is what the
fine strength to me it's not about
lifting something up it's not about when
everything is going good your ear to
champion and everything it's about when
stuff gets bad how do you change it
that's why that's what I feel strength
is and that's why I respect the guy that
are fighting on Saturday well I think
it's a very gracious answer I think it's
very accurate of the black piece but I
would add one to accomplish I will give
you a pat in the back I also think
equally as important is when someone
does have great power it doesn't mean
there is an adversary but when someone
has made it through the adversity how
they wield that what they do is that
you've been a class act as a champion
and that means a lot as well that fight
is happening November 2nd a third I was
I just Thursday I don't say ii don't say
ii don't say ii and i said ii oh he's
gonna kick my ass and I said black beast
and it's gonna be it's gonna be a hate
crime UFC 230 number second Daniel
Cormier thank you so much sir be safe
[Music]
okay first off these are all my toys but
look how many of the toys I get now a
long way Jesus because a mug club and
with that I know but I noticed that
farmers dog which hopper each other
along with cheese's sponsor other
podcasts that shall remain nameless but
they don't even have a dog
no and if I vomit I didn't wanna sponsor
hopper so you are giving some of that
it's a deer to make sense it makes sense
move unless you want hopper to die
join the club a lot of credit comes a
smoke and we get to try for 7 days free
and we're not sponsored by farmers dog
so you know we're not making money and
the other way
all right single live rate of the week
because when Benjamin is not here and
actually Eric had had to go to the
bathroom lateral Carter calm slash mug
club this is where you get to see the
Daily Show every single day full hour
show every day was not actually not on
the weekends and he get access to the
entire see our TV catalog ninety-nine
dollars annually 69 for students
veterans active military and you get
seven days for you get to give it a
whirl especially the time of YouTube and
especially we like going out to U of M
was an incredibly costly endeavor that
took a lot of time and man-hours we
wouldn't be able to do it if not for
Mudd Club members really I can't thank
you enough and if you're looking to
purchase a firearm as well the only
other main sponsor we have in the show
we don't sell it we don't sell you
things every day for single live in
commercial break Walter firearms here's
the deal Google review right now Walther
PPQ that's my favorite gun period just
Google Walther PPQ review you will not
find it you'll have to go to page 10 of
Google to see anything other than
glowing reviews and there are a lot of
good guns yeah it Glocks are great as
there are plenty of Glocks you can go
with a H&K you could go with a Smith &
Wesson you could go with a Sig at that
point sent Mercedes or BMW that being
said I've never anyone has actually
tried the Walther and decided to go with
another firearm so all we ask is try it
and they have the balls to sponsor the
show and of course a lot of credit Icom
slash my clip keeps the lights on on
onward with the show go go hopper stop
that blinking
[Music]
[Music]
that was a very ancient on an older
version that I'd done of that that was
the Greg that was a Louganis little
drowning dance hit my diving board put
aids all over the Olympic pool oh you
okay that's right I think it lost a
break Greg Louganis you know that sorry
Dino I know you know he did that he hit
his head in the backboard blood all over
the pool turns out I think he HIV yeah
that's one way to think there was an
Amen TV film and I think it was Mario
Lopez who played him couldn't even get
Louie diamond white hopes poor guy
that's the worst way to go that really
is to look like I couldn't weekend like
John Leguizamo I don't know I'm doing
the Steven Seagal voice oh and Benjamin
right before we left for U of M were
just watching Steven Seagal films and
one thing that he never gets hit and I
was doing research after saying how does
this happen is he that that is he's like
my there's an actual quote my audience
I'm awesome he really believes his own
he wrote it in to the scripts but he
punch there was a there was a by the way
thank you to Daniel Cormier I was this
close to asking you Daniel if you could
who would win in a fight you or Steven
Seagal because I wanted to piss him off
and see we'd get him to you know storm
off the show he's so nice though Daniel
Cormier he's super nice super nice dude
and I'm really sad it's going to be his
last fight and a really good guy and you
know what I think I think his world
views might surprise you anymore um just
to really he's a hard worker
he's a family man and he's a good guy um
was it about Steven Seagal yeah yeah no
there was a film I don't know the name
of the film I would love it if people
just let me know is send in send in your
tweets and also by the way your
questions life advice at laterals credit
calm are doing a segment next week in a
devil's advocate next week was definite
my on him oh he John like was I don't
know the film was Steven Seagal and John
Leguizamo but apparently he was supposed
to die they were supposed to shoot it at
6 a.m. and they only shot it at 8 p.m.
that day because he just refused to die
he was amazed but my viewers would never
accept this it's highly unrealistic
drink some water say something
quarterblack disgraceful
what's up bros all right do you really
need to get out of that rhythm ok so let
me take off the clown mask it's been I'm
not gonna like it's been a tough spell
it's been a tough spell for a while for
me and I'm incredibly appreciative when
we do these live shows so U of M as an
example was really really hard
required getting a lot of people out
there 17 hour drive most of us flew
one-way drove the other way to try and
kind of pass it off and you know some
things good some things could have gone
better that we had issue we've talked
about if you remember in MO club with
the Union numbers at U of M who didn't
let us get in we were supposed to get in
so they were lining everything it takes
a crew of 12 people is very hard and
very draining physically and listen not
cancer nothing like that but I'm not a
guy who likes to necessarily and my
health isn't it's not in the best of
sorts right now these are things that
are that can be corrected but serious
enough to warn you know I've taken
really a couple sick - sick days in the
history of this company a lot of the
time when people see we're not doing it
they don't realize this we actually were
rebuilding something or were actually re
taping something like I changed my mind
we just can't do it show the day we do
it change my mind or doing U of M that
was days and days of and getting out
several days of travel there might be
some more and and you know what let me
know who you would like to see as a
fill-in host not right now but probably
around Christmas break and one thing I
will say though doing these live shows
which can be really exhausting and they
really can the reaction the interactions
with the the fans that people are really
incredible the people who support the
show Mugler I mean it was crazy to me is
at least 60 to 70 percent of people at
that that theater and by the way at
overflow thousands of people were mug
Club members oh yeah there was a so
that's not even just non Mugler Club
members get their hours in advance so
that's always it really is a team of
people we really do feel like it's
familial and we overwhelm of the support
but I also do notice an ongoing theming
you've probably seen this 2qa
particularly with the upcoming election
fear a theme of people being afraid and
a lot of different people a fine
different ways to get over them a lot of
people find that this show helps then I
had some people say listen man I just
I'm so tired of news and politics this
was a veteran who talked about how he
had been suicidal I actually have a Navy
Cross there we haven't figured that the
perfect place to put it yet so it's just
safe so thank you sir again for sending
it but we're gonna put it right next to
that befitting the ultimate warriors
action figure that mike Ward gave us
that next to a navy cross that
crystallizes this show some people say
this show helps them ah it's really
important though this isn't obviously
the only limbs there appears probably
better than the show because everyone on
the show needs therapy
so understand the difference between
being afraid and I don't always get the
chance to answer people this way and
being afraid of something and being
fearful there are two different things
another's last segment of the week you
know often ends up be I think it ended
up being branded Crowder closes because
people were uploading it anyway like I
want those dollar dollar bills so I try
to be vulnerable I try to be earnest
because I don't think lies help I don't
think being completely disingenuous
helps I don't think false ego helps and
because I know a lot of you out there
might be experiencing some of the same
pain in in fears that I've gone through
or that I'm going through or people even
here sometimes in the studio so if it
helps you it'd be wrong for me to keep
it to myself and I think a lot of you'll
often go you know don't don't be afraid
oh listen to be brave but they don't
really tell you how and if you have so
let's say it's you know the rock or
someone like Daniel Cormier it's why I
really appreciate you appreciate the
interviews with Daniel Cormier because
Daniel Cormier is in a world level
ass-kicker and on this show not always
but on this show he's been very
vulnerable about what it is that scares
him about the fact that he's nervous
before every fight very specific and I
tell you what for me that inspired me
not about you but hearing Daniel Cormier
say I get nervous before we fight I
didn't feel so bad about you know
throwing up or painting the porcelain
before every single live show
quarterblack noses I don't enjoy
I don't enjoy speaking live I get very
very nervous when you get up there you
look really good well thank you I
appreciate the lies checks in the mail
it will clear you needn't say wait it's
gonna clear anyway just like just like a
black belt from Steven Seagal your check
cleared and I'm amazing
so if it does help you the way Daniel
Cormier Brian charge or simpie R Thomas
oh we've had a lot of great people here
who've been we've actually talked
specifically about things they either
scare them or difficulties they've
overcome um that's been something it's
been inspiring to me and so I'm just
gonna be honest were there are a lot of
things that scare me but I don't live my
life let me go through it um and I'd
like to hear you guys
tell me what it is it most gives you
going out on a limb here and I know
it'll be used against me eventually but
I also know that there's someone else
out there who probably feels like
they're alone might think that they're
at the end of their rope and maybe this
will help so it's one person it's worth
it um I'm afraid if I'm afraid of being
alone
that's something I'm really afraid of
this idea you know people talk about
being alone in a crowded room we often
hear in sound lyrics that often happens
I can be surrounded by a lot of Pino who
a friend is or no who necessarily cares
about me and especially when you have so
many supporters and I'm grateful for
them
you're always afraid that that goes away
and that there's just sort of dead still
of quiet I've always been very for me
I'm afraid to be alone I'm afraid of
burning out it's one of one of my worst
fears I'm afraid of burning out like
after a University of Michigan and again
when you have kind of health struggles
nothing serious you just it's hard it's
sometimes it's hard I can always get up
and do the work that I need to do as far
as okay show up hit the mark do the
sketch fine write the joke but when you
don't have anything to aim for sometimes
it's really I just to think up right now
okay where are we gonna do the next
change what's the next super video what
where we gonna go on location because so
much needs to be planned and it's it's
just like you know a lion-tamer it's the
different legs of this tool that keeps
the line completely confused that's the
only reason that this person isn't this
circus clown is not getting eaten I get
overwhelmed sometimes I'm afraid of
burning out I am afraid of not being
deserving with this platform frankly I'm
afraid of that something I've always
been afraid of I see the faces I see
people who come up when they they tell
me their personal stories and how much
this program means them I really am
grateful but I'm a I think I often feel
undeserving I worked really hard you
know I be I try to be honest with people
I probably work harder than anyone I
know and that's kind of a reputation in
the industry if you ask other people I'm
a Clydesdale not a show horse clearly
not an Arabian Prancer dancer whatever
it is all you equestrians I don't care
go do your distress but um I'm afraid I
often feel undeserving of the platform
I'm afraid of mistakes that I've made
which have harmed others and I I don't
necessarily know what they are sometimes
when you're in a leadership position
this keeps me up at night I'm afraid
that have made mistakes that have caused
ripple effects and they were mistakes
that I could've avoided especially when
you know you have
employees in your in your sure in your
mid-20s you make mistakes mistakes are
okay but III I have trouble sleeping
sometimes when I think about I couldn't
that's something that bothers me a lot
I'm afraid the Brazilian Wandering
Spider that goes without saying I'm
afraid of not doing it not knowing when
I've done the right thing that's
something that's hard afraid of the
mistakes and sometimes not knowing if
you've made a mistake or done the right
thing because sometimes you make a
decision that you have to make for
someone else in the team or someone else
in your life that negatively affects one
other person sometimes sometimes it's
just like we don't have that much room
in the lifeboats sometimes you have to
make hard decisions and sometimes you
think you have to make hard decisions
and it's just wrong I'm afraid of that
I'm afraid of
I'm afraid frankly I used to have a bad
temper I'm afraid of becoming back I'm
afraid of mr. Hyde rearing his ugly
bisexual head that was a smoke that was
a short face no I'm afraid afraid of
afraid of getting angry afraid of being
too emotional afraid of being obsessive
because that I'm afraid of alienating
friends family people who I care about
most something I think about a lot
sometimes a lot of pressure sometimes a
lot of compression comes hyper
volatility emotionally and I'm afraid of
pushing people away especially when you
have people who you love who either work
with you or in close proximity this is
I'm afraid of and this is why you might
have seen there was a pause at U of M
I'm afraid of having children I'm really
afraid of having children I said I don't
like kids that's not sure I like kids
that's a smokescreen I kind of don't
like stinky kids but I'm afraid of
having children deathly afraid because
of thrusting them into a life that they
didn't choose I've had a lot of close
calls I've had even just not close calls
I've had very unpleasant encounters
we've had people who just work for this
show who had been spat on we've had
people get violent with them we even at
U of M we had people trying to start a
bar fight for people who weren't even on
stage but they knew worked with the crew
I'm really afraid of having children and
bringing them into that it's always been
something of bothers me because of that
something else I'm afraid
the fact that my fear of having children
could cause irreparable damage with a
wife who I know deserves them not saying
I'm never gonna have kids by the way I'm
just saying it's a street it's a fear
that I struggle with I know a lot of
people struggle with these fears we
talked about the church groups often
when people aren't honest I need to be
forgiven for being a workaholic
I spend too much on Facebook you know
what no I'm telling you exactly what I'm
afraid I'm telling up I'm telling you
what my weaknesses are because I know
and some of these are actually things
that I feel as though I should have
expressed a long time ago because I
constantly encounter these at live
performances where people say you know
what I really struggle with this and you
helped me with it I'm going you know and
I should just tell people I should just
tell people that I struggle with that I
just tell people that I struggle with
with burnout and fear of that or I
should just tell people that I'm afraid
of having children because it might help
them to not feel so alone here that's so
much from the left oh don't be alone
only they try to tell you shouldn't feel
alone in your depravity I'm telling you
shouldn't feel alone of being afraid of
things but hopefully there's a solution
that we'll get to after this I'm afraid
I'm afraid of all of this going away and
15 people being out of a job that's one
thing that really scares me if I'm
undeserving oh it all goes away
or you say the wrong thing that can
happen to anyone these days we've been
really blessed there's 15 other people
who rely on mug club and your support
not just myself that's something that's
really scary here's how you know me and
on this I'm afraid of not being able to
discern the things that I can control
and the things that I can't and wasting
energy trying to fix things or trying to
contain things that I can't control
I'm really afraid of not having
discernment or not having perfect
discernment I think that's what a lot of
these fears stem from and even more I
think I'm I'm afraid of not fixing the
issues that I can control and that would
be even harder to live with so it's a
vicious it's just this never-ending
cycle of what can I control what can I
not and if you can control it you better
do something about it because people are
relying on you to fix this and if it's
out of your control you're spinning your
wheels and the people who are relying on
you they're just gonna see you burn out
and then you can't help them it's it's a
really difficult thing to break it's a
really difficult cycle to break I'm
afraid of all of these things and snake
island
but I don't live in fear and neither
should you and I hear this a lot
particularly this election you shouldn't
live in it's okay to be afraid of things
everyone is afraid bravery is doing the
right thing in the face of being afraid
but living in perpetual fear is
different just like people tell lies but
lying to yourself consistently is
corrosive to your soul in a way that is
very different from telling somebody
they don't look fat in a dress living in
a state of fear is different from being
afraid you do not have to live in fear
regardless the election because you're
not alone and not only are you not alone
because of whether you believe in it or
not God says that you're not alone but
let's get out of you know what people
may see as corny sort of metaphysical
bumper stickers if you're watching this
live right now okay look at how many
people are watching live with you if
you're watching the show afterward just
look at how many subscribers mug
clubbers there are next to you take
solace of knowing there are millions
upon millions of people right now in
arms with you and you know why those
people hit the subscribe button you know
what those people have bought this isn't
it's it's awesome it's hand etched it's
girthy it's hand painted this is just a
symbol
you know why millions of people have
supported this program it's not because
it's it's it's funny every now and then
we get a few right it's not because
people feel so this is the only place
they can go for political information or
insight millions of people have signed
up because they have been through
something similar to what you are going
through or to what you have been through
look at that subscriber count that's the
ceiling right now on YouTube I just lost
my opinion the ceiling for conservatives
on YouTube is our channel right and
that's also a burden that scares us
because we're going man we're changing
the blueprint every single week and
we're trying to do right by it
election it's fluctuate and we get so
many emails especially the life advice
but what what did I do with the election
I feel that our country's done I hear
that every single election elections
change parties change and it goes back
and forth but win lose or draw whether
it's this going on the next go-around
you're not alone you don't need to live
in fear do you feel better at all does
that help you feel better I know
sometimes he shows me feel-good segments
but it doesn't really matter okay
because whether you feel better or not
that's the truth so take it if you feel
better good
now it's your obligation to help the
next guy go
make sure today right now if you're
listening if you're watching this show
immediately I mean pause this there's
only gonna be a few seconds of music
afterward anyway you don't even need to
hear it you've probably heard a song a
million times with Pogo pause it right
after this phrase and immediately going
ashore that somebody else out there
doesn't feel alone and doesn't need to
live in perpetual fear if all of us do
that that's what changes this country
and that's what creates a team and
that's what gives people not only self
belief but belief in their values and
belief in real change make sure today
right now this is the last phrase I'm
getting near the end of this now name
that movie line that you go out and
ensure someone else doesn't feel alone
and doesn't have to live in fear because
that's why we do this we'll see you next
week devil's advocate stefan molyneux
fun
[Music]
you